she's a pop icon she's a legend she was
my OG 90s girl crush okay so I was
technically team Brittany but the
stripped album she just hits different
the woman needs no introduction and
while our girl Christina Aguilera
akaxtina has seemed relatively unfazed
by dye culture growing up in the
spotlight she has recently come onto my
radar for her unconventional and
arguably really strange diet so today
I'll be channeling my inner Lady
Marmalade and eating like Christina
Aguilera
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video I'll be eating like pop
icon Christina Aguilera but you guys
know the drill I'll be dressing
everything up Abby style and turning
into hunger crushing combos that I
actually want to eat a quick disclaimer
that this diet was compiled from primary
and secondary sources so I really can't
speak to the accuracy of Christina's
actual diet it really doesn't matter
though of course because I'm only going
to be using these alleged meals as a
template for teaching gentle nutrition
and for inspiring what I decide to make
for myself this is just what I ate on a
random day and is not meant to be copied
or recommended as how you should eat as
always please speak to a registered
dietitian about your unique needs I'm
gonna hop in here quick to tell you
about a sponsor I'm so excited about
briochio as a full-time content creator
I don't get a lot of messy bun days so
in between regular coloring washing blow
drying and styling my hair is put
through a lot so I'm a bit crazy about
quality hair care and I'm obsessed with
these Geo products no matter what kind
of hair you have or what condition it's
currently in briogeo has a solution they
have products for oily hair dandruff
frizz sensitive skin damaged hair and
everything in between and they're
appropriate for all hair types and
textures I'm currently using the Deep
despair repair hair mask between color
treatments to just balance out protein
and moisture it's actually being
scientifically proven to decrease hair
breakage in just two uses I'm also
really obsessed with the scalp Revival
exfoliating shampoo because I naturally
have a really dry scalp so I am prone to
dandruff and flakes but this is being
clinically shown to decrease up to 82
percent of dry scalp flaking so it has
been a lifesaver for me all of their
products are formulated with a six free
methodology with no harsh sulfate
silicones parabens phthalates artificial
dyes or DEA which is not only good for
our hair but also better for the
environment all their products are also
vegan cruelty free and gluten-free and
most importantly they really do work
I've noticed a huge difference in my
scalp and hair texture since starting my
briochio routine so if you're ready to
try for yoshio for yourself I've got a
special offer for my viewers you can get
15 off of your briochio order by
clicking the link in the description and
entering the code Abby sharp at checkout
okay so before we get into my attempt at
this unusual diet let's set the stage
for the how why and what Christina eats
in a day so as someone who has credited
her ability to stay in shape to laughter
happiness breathing I was a bit taken
aback when I learned about her
commitment to these so-called seven day
color diet which she credits in part to
helping her lose 40 pounds as the name
implies the seven day color die
emphasizes eating colors of the rainbow
for seven days straight to optimize
health and well-being if you guys are
regular subbies here you know I advocate
for counting colors not calories and
research suggests that focusing on
eating a variety of colors helps to
increase our intake of vitamins minerals
and phytonutrients so we love to see it
but of course it wouldn't be a diet
without a solid dose of sensationalism
you can't just eat colorful Foods on
this diet you need to eat foods of one
color every day for 7 seven days
straight so for example on day one you
can eat only white Foods on day two red
Foods on day three green foods and so on
and so forth listen I am all for finding
new ways to increase your fruit and
vegetable intake but does eating one
color a day have any role in weight loss
and are there any downsides to a strict
one color a day diet well we're gonna
find out together but of course since I
don't have the time patience willpower
or budget to eat only one food color
every day we're gonna attempt a single
color at each meal but modify it as
needed for the sake of balance and
enjoyment alright let's get cooking okay
I'm pretty excited about this
um I'm a huge Christina Aguilera fan I
think she's one of the most talented
artists of all time
um and this whole color dye thing like
definitely intrigued me so I'm excited
to dig in because I'm very hungry but
first I want to share this like unusual
little old quote here so according to US
Weekly Christina said I'm not into
depriving myself I limit bad foods I
like I mean there are a lot of
contradictions in that sentence alone
yeah I'm gonna try to overlook that for
a hot minute because I am starving and
I'm in the mood for eggs which is also
one of Christina's go-to breakfast so I
guess that means it's a yellow meal
let's make some eggs all right little
olive oil a little butter because I like
a combo
there are
tiny currents everywhere looks like ants
but it's not my kid had a current frenzy
this morning there's also cereal in my
blender mom life
a couple eggs down
all right
quick little scramble
[Applause]
basically I just emptied out my fridge
of any and all vegetables I could find
that were yellow so we're gonna do some
eggs
which
I'm calling that yellow some eggs are
orange
some eggs are pretty pale
and disappointing but we're going to
start with these eggs and then I will
add in whatever else I found that fits
the bill
yellow tomato had to pay a fortune for
those
some yellow bell pepper a little more
cost effective
I've probably got some corn in the
freezer let's take a look
yep
that's a good one some corn
mmm
I love corn
it's corn
and I got some cheese kind of orange
kind of yellow but I figure orange and
white make yellow
right I gotta go back to art class all
right I can't make an omelet to save my
life so we're just gonna scramble this
all right so I got some whole grain
tortillas here I know not exactly yellow
but close enough I've also got some
hummus which again not exactly yellow
but we're going for it because I was
trying to think about what other kind of
condiment I could use that would fit the
yellow theme and all I could think of
was mustard and the thought of putting
mustard on my eggs felt a little suss so
we're going with hummus we're gonna just
maybe Brody you can color correct this
so it just looks like super super yellow
it doesn't look too badly not
a little bit of hummus but also maybe
that's weird too this whole diet is
forcing me to come up with the most
unusual unorthodox food combinations I
have ever encountered you know I'm all
about
I'm all about trying new things
this is either going to be terrible or
it's going to be great we're going to
see corn bell peppers tomato
some cheese and eggs it's a new one for
me but how bad could it be I mean all
these ingredients are pretty delicious
this is just bagging bagging for a
little like
a little hot sauce or like a ketchup
parsley for sake I don't even like
parsley but I would die for a sprig of
parsley right now but but you know it's
yellow so I feel like we accomplished
something
and it tastes really good I mean we got
lots of protein in our eggs and some in
the hummus we got fiber rich carbs in
our mango and our tortilla and our
veggies and some fats in our cheese and
our eggs and some hummus I mean it's
ugly as but it hits the spot
plus yellow Foods pack a major nutrition
punch Abby tell us more you got it Abby
so yellow fruit and veggies get their
pigment from phytonutrients lutein and
zeaxanthin which are also found in some
non-plant foods like egg yolks these
unique antioxidants are key for
supporting Eye Health by reducing
inflammation improving sharpness of
vision and may even lower the risk of
cataracts and other age-related eye
diseases and conditions but if you don't
love all things yellow they're actually
heavily concentrated in leafy greens as
well and speaking of greens I think it's
time for lunch Abby over to you yeah so
according to style craze lunches
typically some kind of salad I mean
seems like a typical celebrity diet so I
think naturally we're gonna have to go
green I'm gonna do some kind of like a
pasta salad and I basically I'm just
gonna like pull out all the green stuff
from my fridge again not sure how it's
all going to go together but yeah we're
going to try to follow the rules as best
as we can okay we're going to make a
pasta pesto salad and I know I'm using
like regular old beige protein pasta
instead of like the green veggie pasta
because let's be real a piece of
broccoli could like fart on that green
pasta and they can say that it contains
actual real veg so I would rather just
have the pasta that has a little more
protein and fiber
we forgot to check if it's rolling
I'm gonna throw in some chopped broccoli
just in that last few minutes of cooking
all right so to cool this down I'm going
to add in some frozen edamame and that's
also gonna thaw out the edamame a little
trick there folks I'm gonna add a
handful of celery just because it's
green we got some arugula also green and
to make the pasta Green you see where
I'm going
I've got some basil pests
now everything's green
smells good add a little avocado here
this actually looks really good and then
let's pull later up all right let's top
it off with some pistachios also green
we love that honestly usually when I
make a salad for me it's all about
having different textures and flavors
and colors but I'm actually pretty
excited about this Abby talk green to me
there's a reason why we're encouraged to
eat our greens and that's because leafy
green vegetables are packed with
nutrients like B vitamins a c e folate
fiber potassium magnesium and vitamin K
with one meta-analysis finding that
daily consumption of green leafy
vegetables may reduce our cardiovascular
disease risk by 16 they also happen to
be a natural source of nitrates and
despite nitrate-free products gaining a
lot of popularity in health circles
eighty percent of the nitrates that we
consume actually come from plant foods
like leafy veg and nitrates aren't all
bad I mean research suggests that die
nitrates may help to lower blood
pressure by dilating blood vessels and
increasing blood flow just more evidence
of the complexity of nutrition and why
reducing nutrition down to individual
food components is not always useful all
right let's recap we have protein and
edamame and the protein pasta we've got
healthy fats in our pesto plus our nuts
and our avocado we have lots of fiber in
all of these amazing vegetables I threw
in there plus the pasta as well and it's
all ingredients that I actually
genuinely really like
hmm
that's good all right well let's talk
snack so according to sources
Christina's diet rolls are not just to
eat in colors so she also has no sweets
or sugar no alcohol no unhealthy
snacking whatever that means she has to
drink two liters of water a day and has
to have three meals and two snacks
so I guess it's snack time and naturally
I'm feeling like something red okay so I
realize it's like virtually impossible
to eat by specific colors and not
consume any added sugar really more
evidence as to why a diet like this is
stupid
so yes there is a bit of added sugar in
This Yogurt because it's like strawberry
flavored but I'm really not concerned
about that because it's packaged up with
lots of protein we got fat in the yogurt
and I'm adding in some extra fiber with
our berries and you know what just to
throw shade at this stupid [__] rule
I'm gonna go into my kids Halloween bag
and get out some red M M's
all right
Brody I thought I included in my rider
to only give me the red M Ms what am I
going to do with all this
I mean does it count if the chocolate
inside is it red though
okay
I want to hear it and you know what I
say about this red day rule I
I'm gonna eat a purple one
I like red
yeah so the color red typically denotes
lycopene and anthocyanins anthocyanins
are responsible for the Deep Red pigment
in foods like berries and cherries
whereas lycopene is responsible for the
brighter Reds that we get from Tomatoes
bell peppers watermelon Etc regardless
of the what and where you get your dose
both antioxidants are anti-inflammatory
in nature and help to support heart
health and cognitive function and may
even protect against chronic diseases
like cancer okay so I'm gonna go get my
kiddos from school and I'll meet you on
the flip side
okay so this dumb diet is getting
progressively more challenging and at
the end of the day so I'm feeling tired
so I'm gonna take the easiest and least
aesthetically pleasing route and go
white and hopefully my kids will
actually eat some of this because who
doesn't like white food and yes I know
white Foods tend to have a really bad
reputation in the health world but are
there any actual benefits to foods that
are white Abby yup white plant foods
like cauliflower garlic onions potatoes
mushrooms and bananas are loaded with
flavonoids like anthoxanthin and
curcerin they're also full of fiber and
other essential vitamins and minerals so
while technically white Foods don't
really fit into the eat the rainbow memo
they still deserve a rightful place on
our plates excellent because I am
craving white rice so we're gonna put
together a kind of like stir fry
situation using all the white things I
have in my fridge I considered using
Mayo but you guys know how I feel about
that and I also thought about using an
alfredo sauce because your girl is
getting desperate for ideas here but I
figured I would get a lot of hate mail
for that so we're going to try to
makeshift a color free Curry free curry
sauce
to my knowledge there isn't really a
recipe for curry sauce that includes
only white ingredients so this might
taste like but we're gonna do our best
to add whatever kind of white flavor we
can got some garlic
good amount of that and some ginger
exactly way but close enough
just gonna let that cook down probably
should have gotten an onion
why is this such a tight one I want the
oh
so tight
this is gonna be the worst cooking job I
ever do because I'm just genuinely
unenthusiastic about this meal coconut
I do not know how much to end
what the ratio of water to cream we are
just flying by the seat of our pants
here folks I mean it smells good let's
just
start to add some stuff actually I feel
like I need to taste this the feeling
it's going to taste like garlic ginger
in the Coconut that would be a good
guess Brody
actually pretty good could it use lime
yes but lime is green so we needed to
use that for our green meal I think it's
pretty good all right let's just add
some [__] to it frozen cauliflower
potatoes that I rinsed to try to make
more white those are definitely yellow
leftover chicken
oh one of these things is not like the
other remove that all right cooked white
rice
that needs to be desperately rewarmed I
found some water chestnuts in my pantry
I love water chestnuts
throw some of those in there they are
also white we want to add lots of white
flavor we need lots of white sesame
seeds
I feel like that's gonna help okay let's
just stir it looks more like risotto
actually tastes pretty good I mean
coconut milk you can't go wrong all
right let's just like let that
cauliflower dethaw a little bit more and
we can plate her up
I was just staring at it thinking how
disappointed it looks like I don't want
this
looks like baby food let's try to make
it better uh I got some cashews here
which used to be white but then they got
toasted so yeah so yeah we're kind of
breaking the rules again but I have to
at this point because
I can't just eat white uh also more
sesame seeds because I feel like that at
least will add a lot more flavor so one
time I did this guy we went on one day
on this dinner date he tells me that
he's a picky eater and he only likes
white food I figured he meant white
people food like he didn't like foods
from other cultures which was honestly a
first red flag for me because I'm a
foodie but no we get to the restaurant
and he proceeds to explain that he only
eats foods that are white white chicken
white rice no vegetables needless to say
I pulled an emergency
my friend needs my help move and I got
the [__] out of there so that's so this
is Conjuring up some deep dark memories
for me that I really thought I buried
but anyways let's talk about the stats
we got some protein in our chicken carbs
in our rice lots of fiber in our veggies
here we got cauliflower water chestnuts
potatoes that are not exactly white but
whatever healthy fats in the Sesame
coconut and the nuts it looks like [__]
but let's give her a try
not bad but not great yeah my kids
aren't going to eat this not even poppy
no all right so I got this deep and
delicious cake for like five bucks I
figured we could make it look
they only sent me
just kidding I ate it
um so yeah we're gonna Gussy this up a
little bit to make it look a little more
Gourmet and turn it into a hunger
cushion combo no need to fear Brown babe
especially if we're talking chocolate as
it's loaded with antioxidants like
polyphenols in fact Studies have found
that the polyphenols in dark chocolate
may help to lower our cholesterol so
yeah I bet you didn't see that one
coming not only that but a two ounce
piece of dark chocolate contains about
40 percent of our daily iron needs
making it an excellent snack during that
time of the month go for it Abby all
right I got some brown pear
I got some almond butter which I'm gonna
kind of like swirl into the chocolate
chocolate and almond natural pairing
right right Beauty got some air here
beautiful and top it off with some
crushed almonds okay so we broke some
stupid rules with the cake but I love A
good rule break we've got fiber in our
pear plus healthy fats fiber and protein
in the almond butter and the almonds and
I don't know about you but I think it
looks a lot more delicious than the OG
hmm
not frosting she just hits different
okay let's recap shall we there's
nothing magical about a diet that tells
you to eat one color of a food every day
like most diets it just tries to
sneakily limit variety especially when
combined with other kind of diet rules
like no sweets and sugar or no unhealthy
snacking whatever that means I mean if
you're limited to just eating green
Foods in a day how much can you possibly
eat of just like leafy greens and veg
ditto for basically any other color
other than maybe white yellow and
possibly red if you eat a lot of beef so
if you do lose weight on a diet like
this it's not because of the lycopene on
red day or the chlorophyll on green day
it's just because you're forced to eat
less yes eating colorful food is super
important but never would I recommend a
diet like this for weight loss or for
just General Health we eat with our eyes
and there is nothing satisfying about
just eating a plate full of yellow
actually this day probably made me crave
color even more even though it was
allegedly all about color a rainbow is
beautiful because all of the colors are
represented together it would never be
the Marvel that it is if we only ever
saw it in parts so I guess let that be a
metaphor for a beautiful varied diet and
on that note that's all that I have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on Whose diet you'd like
to see me attempt next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]